don't bring anyone love into this
speaking of drinks so you got to watch
Burt drink for two and three days entire
day so track so we started a Saturday
night we went out to dinner we all had a
few drinks and then we went back to the
he got an Airbnb and we chilled there
and then the next day we went to we went
to brunch
they really wanted to do a like a
southern brunch that's fun so I start
with mimosas and you know Burt had like
three or four and I think Ari and I had
one or two and then we go to top golf
and so we we go there and he's just like
TT goes in soda oh pretty good couple
more and then starts just doing that I'm
actually like I had a few drinks last
night I'm a lightweight I go I just need
to rehydrate so I'm he's drinking water
water and water wasn't you know the
water God's okay so I'm doing that
always having Bloody Mary's but he's
having like one for every two doubles
that is and by the way Bert's killing it
it is a great golf swing so he's just
like playing well so he has I don't know
we estimate he was like I think I'd like
five we're like I think you had like
seven and we settled on six which is
being generous this is on golf day yes
so we leave there and then we go home
have a drink at the house so here's
another one there huh then we go to a
cigar lounge before dinner he has two
more doubles at the cigar line doubles
doubles now this is the question tom
you're saying that Bert's drinking six
drinks but he's drinking doubles correct
at each drink right so actually twelve
drinks when you're saying six yeah so so
if you have the let's say the mimosas
let's not even count them orange yeah so
six doubles at top golf we go over to
the house he has another right there
seven okay that's two more at the cigar
lounge that's 9 1 hat dinner okay
one after
with the staff okay he has a shot with a
chaser and then one last one so that's
cash it's an additional one two three
four so that's what well let's add it up
I'm not really good at math it's
thirteen thirteen and six it's nineteen
so but times two there's a double
they're all doubles 30 yeah I say like
38 drinks Wow so that's a lot dude he 38
I made a dinner reservation I fucked up
Jesus I thought it was for later so when
I when I screwed up we had to like
figure out where to drink until well no
we're gonna get dinner cuz it's Sunday
night we're like shit and every place I
look up it's closed so I finally find
there's a roofs Chris I wear Ruth's
Christmas Christmas Christmas yeah
Carl's jr. service Chris yeah we go
there and he's when he uh he goes the
bathroom when he comes back he's like I
don't know he's a long try the bread man
it's hot he's like okay and then the
whole like five people from the staff
come back and they're like oh my god he
got recognized and told them hey wait
like two minutes then come back and
recognize me in front of the guys
so they're like burnt oh my god we're
such big fans okay but then they were
like talking about your mom's house
they're like God personality I'm like
they're all its fans of podcasts and
stand-up but he had them come back and
like act like they were a they
recognized us it's so weird
holy shit and then we hung out with like
he was like hanging out with the staff
and I'm like what are you doing
he's like business the best I was like
do you do this
after every show he's like yeah he sits
there and shuts it down just keeps
drinking and well that's what it is yeah
it's the drinks that keep flowing past
closing but yeah he just like to keep
the party going he's a lot of fun when
we went to the game we got stuck in line
outside and he turned that into like a
party just like yelling shit to people
one guy was yelling at him like fuck you
man cuz we skipped a bunch of people in
line
and what are you allowed to because of
your ticketing or you just were just
know we were jerks I paid a I paid a guy
Oh smart yeah but we couldn't get up
that far but we did get to skip a bunch
of people and this guy was really pissed
him and his dad he was probably I don't
know late 20s and his dad was late 50s
he's a little guy and he was like mother
fucker get the fucking line like really
get really aggressive and first like
dude we're on television we have to get
in there to work and like making a scene
like with the production crew and when
we didn't get any further the guy said
what happened your television he's like
dude googled me I'm on TV and the guy
goes what's your name and bird goes Tom
Segura Oh jerk and the guy goes your
name is piece of shit oh my gosh he's
like hey dude he was you're talking a
lot for a little guy like and I could
feel the tension
yeah it'd have actually died down but it
definitely was a pretty heated
[Music]